we have talked about it non-stop on this
show economists are no better than
casino gamblers
we just got the non-farm payroll numbers
the estimate was that we were going to
get
500 000 new jobs
we got under 200 000
less than 50 percent
what is going on
the u.s labor september non-farm payroll
the consensus
the entire market had agreed on the
estimate of 500 000 it came in under 200
000.
you literally could put a blindfold on
spin around and throw darts and probably
be more accurate than these people
that is absurd if you went to work every
day and you are off by more than 50
percent month after month after month
after month after month
after month after month after month
eventually you would be fired
it is unacceptable that we have economic
estimates that are this far off if you
say hey every once in a while we're off
by 10 i get it it's a complex economic
system there's tons of variables there's
tons of inputs that drive these numbers
but to miss this bad and have us talk
about it month after month after month
is a joke
we should either stop estimating
or
we should start to see what the
repercussions are because there are
financial decisions being made on the
estimates
some people are buying assets some of
them are selling assets some of them are
waiting for the numbers and trading and
the people who end up being the least
effective trading around these numbers
are those that are the least
sophisticated the retail traders
so if we are going to have estimates and
they continue to be this far off you at
home have to realize it's never going to
change they're going to continue to
estimate inaccurately i wish that there
was a way to bet on whether they had an
accurate estimate or not
if there was a way to bet on every
non-farm payroll day or the release of
the numbers and i could simply say i
think they got it right or i think they
didn't i don't even need to know the
numbers i'm betting they didn't get it
right and i'd be a very very very rich
person because you could literally bet
the house every time
that's how absurd their inaccuracy is
but we continue to play this charade
nobody's calling out the nonsense nobody
says
wait why are they off by more than 50
percent
how is that possible well it's because
when you look at bad data and you have
astrology astrology-like models that
literally just make things up you just
come up with made-up numbers like 500
000 and then real number comes in at
194k
if you
were taking a test in school
and you were off by that much you would
get an f
fail
they would literally say if you get this
score on every test
you don't get credit for the class you
failed it's an f
and so at some point we have to ask
ourselves how much of monetary and
fiscal policy is being driven by the
data and the analysis of the same exact
people that are this inaccurate if we
have bad data
there's no way we can make good
decisions you need good data to make
good decisions but what we've seen time
and time again
is just a whiff
this is pathetic in my opinion
right
yeah i mean look we're way off but i
think the other thing to note is that
we're way down from last month right so
growth is supposed to be accelerating at
this point job growth as we get out of
the pandemic and as we return to normal
do all these things it's slowing down
it's stalling right and you have some uh
economist online and on on twitter
saying oh it's seasonal now they're
calling it seasonal they're saying the
government employees uh their jobs are
seasonal and we shouldn't have added as
many because of that stop with the
transitory the seasonal stop with the
words uh to cover up that you're wrong
right so uh the they've been wrong about
these estimates time and time again last
month i think yeah we were at uh 366 k
jobs added last month after revisions
this month we're at 194 on an estimate
of 500. so we've stalled dramatically
and if you look at kind of the whole of
where we're supposed to be on an
expected job basis based on kind of just
current growth trends we're still about
nine million jobs in the hole and that
if you look on it kind of compared to
the rest of history that's about where
we were at the bottom at the bottom pit
of the 08 recession right so like it's
really really really bad and it's not
getting any better we're not going to
get anywhere near close to that 9
million jobs number anytime soon based
on the growth already stalling kind of
when we're supposed to be exiting the
pandemic on top of that there's 11
million open jobs in the economy world
record number of open rolls it's not a
demand it's not a supply problem there's
literally 11 million open jobs at the
moment
it just exploded look at the growth of
open roles right after the pandemic and
now all of a sudden we're saying oh but
we can't get people to go back to work
if there's this many open roles
and there's only 194 thousand people
going back to work and we're seeing a
slowdown there's no tapering coming
there's no sort of slowdown in the
economic stimulus the only thing that
central banks can do is they can
manipulate the interest rates or they
can provide more liquidity to the market
through things like quantitative easing
and if you have the economic slowdown
from a job growth standpoint and you
have this many open roles you still have
over five percent unemployment and you
have cpi'd over five percent core
inflation over four percent
this is a disaster
this is an absolute disaster that we
have on our hands on top of that more
people have died of covet in 2021 than
in 2020
so not only are we not addressing the
public health crisis
but also we're not addressing the
economic crisis either
so what is going on
and i don't see anyone coming out and
saying here's the plan here's how we're
going to address the issues here is the
light at the end of the tunnel instead
what you're seeing is more and more and
more people are actually losing hope and
ultimately that's the problem is when
people lose hope they give up on
searching for a job they actually just
relegate themselves to a life
of just despair and dire financial
situation that's not the way it should
be we live in the most prosperous most
democratic most capitalistic society in
the world
we should not have these problems you
should not go talk to business owners
and say
how is it and then say i literally can't
get people to come work at my business
and then go talk to other people and
they say we have the high unemployment
rate of over five percent right now
what's going on
i don't think that anyone has the
answers but what i do know is that we
can't continue to have interventions in
the market because the more that you
take away those free market forces you
get nonsense like this this is a
manipulated economy it's a manipulated
asset prices it's manipulated monetary
and fiscal policy and so what do we get
we get
an economy that makes zero sense